pascal you mentioned you're not really
into writing that you don't really like
to write but of course you wrote the
script on the horizon yeah what are
those first days like and what's your
process like to finish it I thing is the
the white pages yes I think is just a
boring some people love to write they
strive on it then oh my god i wrote so
many pages sometimes it's fun when
something works and something is easy
but just the process of writing
formatting it's just I think it's just
boring and it takes it's not it doesn't
take a long time it's just it's just a
process I prefer I'm a visual person I
love to shoot to see beautiful thing
that's that's way more fun so that's why
it's just like for example I know now
I'm I'm preparing my other feature film
and I like okay now it's time for the
writing part and I get an idea but still
it's like okay now I want to make sure
and that's a thing I've learned so much
for my first feature film now i'm going
to apply everything by second but still
the same process goes back to first line
of the page one so that's that's what I
kind of dislike well you said that you
your first choice would be to be a
musician and that you really resonate
with music yeah do you feel that you're
a better writer when you have certain
emotional music playing cool that you
can just channel stuff that you can't
even put into words yeah totally and
some of my best work was based on music
when some time I have a song already I
see images but sometimes just seen and
sometimes that scene is great but does
it fit in a whole piece and does it does
it fit let's say in a feature film you
have a great scene but doesn't sometimes
that's what I'm learning now it doesn't
mean that you can you cannot force a
scene that is so great into a feature
film if that doesn't work sometime we
can be just a short film something can
be four totally different story and but
yet music for me it's a big big drive
but I'm trying to do things differently
now of just focusing on characters and
the story itself and then you had the
sauce you know the music and then the
location and stuff like that but I know
that for example I just for on the
horizon we had the theme song of the
film and when I heard that
it's just like it click like that yeah
yeah oh and does he eat the beginning
and did you do do do do and then I start
writing and it made sense so yeah it's
it's it's fuel to my imagination where
did you first hear that song it was the
guy that I was searching on soundcloud
them for music and i was just i wrote
ambient and then one guy pop up and I
heard one of the song that he did it was
super electro 80s vibe and I saw just
the melody behind the song if you remove
all the craziness that the big lecture
that I didn't like but it's the melody
behind it I was just like that's my
theme song so I wrote the guy I say hey
I'm doing a feature film I love your
song and do you want to do a remix
version for my film is like yeah yeah so
we start working on it and I'm I love
music so I know what works what doesn't
work I'm not a composer itself but I
know that when you send me something
that how to change it and so it was a
beautiful collaboration with the
composer we had two composer that did
completely two different style but they
brought something that worked for
example the ending of on the horizon
it's a we had a big song of 14 minutes
it's a long indian song but just clicked
everything together and i was having a
hard time just how do i do that do i put
no music it's just gonna be sound design
but then when i heard that song it just
made everything flawless and that's what
I've learned a lot my next thing is
going to be just full of music from
start to finish but music is a very
delicacy to play with because it can
destroy your film or you can make it
right and and I felt you used music to
show emotion incredibly well in the film
was there more than just one musician
that was involved in nusajaya composers
but i thought i read about twenty five
bands yeah we got a lot of Bend we have
two composer who created the songs in
the film but mostly when it's when
there's a lyrics or people singing that
was real been so we had think nine ten
bands and and again it goes back that
when you have a piece of work like let's
say you have short film and stuff like
that it's easier to just hey guys here's
my demo reel I'm doing a feature film I
would love to use one song
in my film I'll give you exposure I'll
give you credit in the poster film blah
blah blah gonna have a copy and we can
sell the music on itunes I'm going to
give you a profit blah blah blah so when
it's at least you're doing something fun
and creative and the quality is there a
lot of people is going to be eager to
jump in but if you kind of do shitty
work then there's a good chance that
people will not give their music and
I've been refused a lot of time people
not giving their songs sometimes is the
publishing writer stuff like that the
big company who doesn't want to give the
song but mostly when you write the bend
directly they're super open about it and
I've been lucky that's the button for my
film music has been everything and I've
been super lucky to get amazing bands
I've never really had a big problem
finding music but it's hard to find the
right song for the right moment I first
of all the the intro of on the horizon
we had a five-minute segment of the
credit and this the the band was Silver
Swan and I found that song it is just
like that's it you know but yeah that
song represent a lot of emotion if you
check the film all the lyrics are there
for a reason it's not just there for fun
the lyrics represent the emotion and
that's why some time I love not to write
dialogue sometimes it's just the music
will do it itself that's why there's a
lot of dreamy sequence in my films
because i think is stronger to let the
audience think what they want to think
instead of just like years here's what
I'm trying to give you an enemy when
you're searching for this music so I
know for the opening I think you said
you typed in ambient and then you found
this person but like other times let's
suppose there's the fight scene or
different things where there's there's a
harder edge of motion what are you
typing in if you're going on soundcloud
or wherever i'm not a big fan oh just
let's put music to put music for example
the big scene in horizon weather in the
white desert there was a big argument
and I didn't want music because I know
if I wanted to put music now it will be
maybe a little bit so p you know it's
just like lead I'm trying to make you
feel something so and I wanted to just
be about the characters and the anger
and the conflict and
but when it's time to be dreamy romantic
whatever then it's just easier but you
that's a thing you have to be picky
about music otherwise you can destroy
your film so you need to place if you're
going to do some kind of music sometime
it can just be some kind of a drone
darker mood there's just to elevate some
of the scene but i'm not a big Hollywood
like dot dot I don't care about that
right I noticed with a lot of European
films they excellent use of music in
that they just sometimes just use one
keyboard note right and that's totally
effective where's yes i agree american
films beat you over the head with like
this Dada and then and so it's almost
like the music is is a third character
it is in a location our music and and
yet some always even with them I we're
working on the next time right now and
we have this claim song already and I
said the same thing I say we need to
make something that is so simplistic
because for me I think when it's so
complex you lose the magic of it so
sometimes just the simple three notes
can be just magical that's really can
drive the emotion home so but you need
talent you know you need to work with
great composer who knows how to create
those moments so do they see they see a
rough cut of the film with no music no I
just tell them scenes or sometimes I was
just like I need that kind of vibe with
this dis and because when I ate it I
like to have my song already because it
changed everything you know if when you
have read about the ending I did the
editing but when I headed the song with
the 14-minute songs it changing anything
so that's why I'm even frame no you said
because they are music Ben or they are
composer that love for me for example I
said hey send me anything that you have
that is new and he says oh I got this
song but I think I'm not sure and
then he send me that song it was exactly
the song of the end of aunty rise and I
was like this is the song it's like are
you sure like I don't like it like it is
perfect send me that so I'm not a big
fan of let's create something for the
film 40 images I love to just use stuff
that it's right there that they already
did from their self that can be on an
album for example and then i'm using
that
directly so i decide i don't know that's
how I prefer to it's more natural for me
to use that and then you can manipulate
on the timeline as to hmm should I move
it up here a little more so it's yeah I
prefer to move my images and then I've
the song itself because if I fall in
love with the song my pieces will move
automatically so even for then my other
project I'm like yeah let's create
something there's going to be the same
vibe but still melancholy and that I and
I just let them grow and I said give me
a little 30-second clips of what you're
creating and then when I see something
that I love I said oh let's dig this
let's make it eight minutes and then he
go but I've been really lucky to find
that guy that I'm that I did on the
horizon with did they've been there two
guys but they're they're just been both
amazing completely different process for
each guy one was more self-made like we
tweak this song compared to the other
one was music that it was from an album
that was ambient but work perfectly with
the images so
you